LAURENCE MORONEY:
Today, I'm meeting
with Paige from Google Search
to talk about the coolness that
is Now on Tap.
So, Paige, you're
a Product Manager
for Google Now on Tap, right?
PAIGE DUNN-RANKIN: Right.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So, tell me
all about Google Now on Tap.
What is it?
PAIGE DUNN-RANKIN: It's
a new feature for Android
Marshmallow, and it helps
bring me related information
and actions.
Whatever I'm doing on my phone,
I can just use Now on Tap
to get information and actions.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Ooh,
are you going to show me?
PAIGE DUNN-RANKIN: So, here is
a chat with my friend Brian.
So, he says, hey, thanks for
picking me up at the airport,
gives me his flight
number, and then
I'm asking him about dinner.
So, what I would typically
do in this situation
is copy and paste
some of these things.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
PAIGE DUNN-RANKIN: You look
up the flights number--
LAURENCE MORONEY: It's awkward
to copy with your fingers.
PAIGE DUNN-RANKIN: --and
you might check out
a couple different apps to
see about the restaurant he
suggested.
So, with Now on Tap, it
makes all of that super easy.
You tap and hold on the
Home button right there.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
PAIGE DUNN-RANKIN: And then
you get all this information
and actions--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, nice.
PAIGE DUNN-RANKIN: --related
to what you are doing.
So, here is the restaurant
that he suggested.
Here is the flight.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
There's his flight.
Oh, and he's delayed.
PAIGE DUNN-RANKIN: I can see
it's delayed, so that's useful.
I can create a calendar
event for this dinner
that we're having.
And it actually used
natural language
to predict this calendar event,
which I think is pretty cool.
Because we had mentioned
dinner, tonight, and the place
all in different parts
of the conversation,
and it combined all of
those into one action.
And so it's trying to
predict what I want to do
and also what
information I need.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, cool.
Now, beyond just the information
in a chat like this, can it
also, when you're in
a particular location,
it can predict
the kind of things
that you do based on time?
Is that right?
PAIGE DUNN-RANKIN: So, that's
more of like a Google Now use
case.
So, Now on Tap is
actually building
on top of what Google
Now has already done.
So, Google Now predicts what's
going on in the real world
and what information you need
that's happening around you.
Now on Tap is about what's
happening on your phone.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, OK.
Cool.
PAIGE DUNN-RANKIN: And so, when
we were thinking about this,
this was one of these
crazy ideas we had.
What if you could get
Now cards for what's
on your screen at any moment,
any screen that you're on?
LAURENCE MORONEY: When you were
working on this kind of thing,
it must have been really
challenging and exciting
to think about the context of
what people do on their phones.
How was that?
PAIGE DUNN-RANKIN: Yeah.
It was a completely new idea.
It was something that's never
really been done before.
And so we looked at
a ton of screens.
We were all donating
our screens as data.
And we had people going
through their top apps
and making sure Now
on Tap worked well.
And yeah, it was a
totally new project
that started out as just a
small team doing some prototypes
and then grew into this product
that we launched in less than a
year.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
And it's in Android
Marshmallow, right?
PAIGE DUNN-RANKIN: Right.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So, cool!
So, if I'm an app
developer and I
want to take advantage of
something like this, what do
I need to do?
PAIGE DUNN-RANKIN: So, the
great thing about Now on Tap
is that developers don't
really have to do anything.
And so it just works
automatically on most apps.
There are a couple of
things that we really
recommend you do.
So, one of those is getting
your app into App Indexing.
Basically, if you
have information
that should appear in
search-- so, for example, you
have Yelp with a
bunch of Yelp reviews,
or IMDB with a bunch
of pages about actors--
we actually show
those apps in search
if you've gone through and
participated in App Indexing.
And that's where we know exactly
where to go within Now on Tap.
So, if you noticed, we have all
those app icons on the cards.
And then when you
click on those,
it goes to exactly
the right place.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, wow.
PAIGE DUNN-RANKIN: And the way
that we do that is we actually
know from search
where to point to.
One of the other
issues that we have
is when people do crazy
things with views.
And so that's a little
more rare, but as long
as your app is basically working
well with accessibility, APIs,
and such like that, it should
work well with Now on Tap.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
What kind of stuff
did you guys encounter while
trying to build something
into Android?
PAIGE DUNN-RANKIN:
One of the things
that was really exciting
for me was seeing
how the API was designed.
So, Now on Top is actually
built on top of an open API.
So it's an API that
anyone can build
an assistant that
takes advantage
of this information about the
view underlying on the screen
and also this layer that
comes up on top of the page.
And so that was really cool
to actually design that API
and work with the Android team.
And then we also had some
pretty funny challenges.
It was actually pretty
hard to tell from context
what you should be showing.
I guess it sounds hard, right?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Sure.
PAIGE DUNN-RANKIN:
And it was hard.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I'm sure
some things went wrong
along the line.
PAIGE DUNN-RANKIN: Yeah.
We had funny-- you know how
there's a band called Yes?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yes.
PAIGE DUNN-RANKIN: We would
trigger for things like that.
And it was a little bit
dumb at the beginning.
But then we started
seeing these things
and then fixing
them, sort of tuning
to the context around the words.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So, what,
if I was in a messenger
chat with a friend and the
word "yes" was in there,
and I did Now on Tap--
PAIGE DUNN-RANKIN: Yeah, you
might get a card for the band.
LAURENCE MORONEY: --then I'd
hear all about Jon Anderson.
PAIGE DUNN-RANKIN: Right.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, I love it.
I'm sure lots of other things
could go interestingly wrong
with that.
PAIGE DUNN-RANKIN: Yeah.
One of the things that we
have actually struggled with
is making sure to
always find something
useful on every screen.
Because, if you can
imagine, there's
just not entities perfectly
spelled out on every screen.
So, one thing that we introduced
that I think is really cool
is basically ways to
find trending searches
on your screen.
We actually know a lot of people
are searching for right now.
And so we can actually
incorporate that into Now
on Tab.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That's pretty cool.
And, obviously, we're just
talking about English right
now.
So, it's also available
in other languages, right?
PAIGE DUNN-RANKIN: Yeah.
At this point,
we're launched in I
think eight or more languages.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
PAIGE DUNN-RANKIN: And it was
a challenge, you can imagine.
This all relies on natural
language processing,
and so you really have to know
all the nuances and the quirks
of the different
languages in order
to not make those types
of "Yes" examples,
those bad-- "overtriggering"
is what we call it.
And so--
LAURENCE MORONEY:
"Overtriggering."
I'll have to remember that one.
Whenever I try to speak
French and insult somebody,
I'll just say "I'm
overtriggering!"
[LAUGHTER]
PAIGE DUNN-RANKIN: Yeah.
So, luckily, we had a team
in Japan dedicated to this.
We also had a lot of
engineers in Europe.
That's where the core
Now on Tap team is based.
And so they all speak
like seven languages.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
Nice.
PAIGE DUNN-RANKIN: Yeah.
They were able to help out.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
And it works just as well.
PAIGE DUNN-RANKIN:
You know, Now on Tap
is actually really useful.
Some engineers in Japan
have been telling me
it's really useful
for them, because it's
hard to type out
all the characters.
Copy and paste is even more
useful in Japanese, basically.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That's true, yeah.
Of course.
PAIGE DUNN-RANKIN: And so Now
on Tap is incredibly helpful.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, nice.
So, back to developers.
You did mention App Indexing.
And App Indexing is part of it.
But I hear you've got some
great resources for developers
for everything that they
need to get into Now on Tap.
PAIGE DUNN-RANKIN: Yeah.
If you're really interested in
making your app work perfectly
with Now on Tap and learning
about these assistant APIs,
I suggest taking a look at
our developer docs on this.
We have a great article that's
all about the Assist APIs.
LAURENCE MORONEY: One
article's all they need.
PAIGE DUNN-RANKIN: Yeah,
it's really pretty simple.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
Well, thank you, Paige, and
thanks for coming today.
PAIGE DUNN-RANKIN:
Thank you so much.
This was great.
LAURENCE MORONEY: If you've
got any questions for me,
or if you have any
questions for Paige,
just please leave them
in the comments below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Google Developers channel
on YouTube.
Thank you.